it's legal it's legal yes it's legal oh  my God this is legal how on Earth is  this league because the kids because the  king doesn't move  yeah but that's why it's so confusing  this Restless episode yeah that's okay  you got checked but okay I'm not moving  my king I'm just moving The Rook  oh my God  I actually remember the only time I play  960 I played a tournament of 960. I  tricked my opponent like that I played a  combination that stopped castling and I  was like hmm if he castles it's equal  but I don't think he knows that it's  legal  my opponent I asked him after the game  did you know you could Castle legally he  was like I can't Castle here I was like  yes he can  wow yes so basically that the king is  crossing or not crossing the line that's  the yeah but okay this is very confusing  yeah and does it change much about the  position because like the king is now  officially stuck on the King on the  queen side